Welcome to
Google Developers Hackademy,
this is the 4th part of the
Google Apps Script course
created by Antonio Guzman
from GDG Androidtitlan Mexico.
If this is your first contact
with the course,
I recommend you watch it
in order and do the exercises.
Welcome to the 4th lesson
of the Google App Script
introduction course.
I'm Antonio Guzman.
Today we will integrate a script
to a Google Form
and we'll communicate it
through the Gmail service.
Today's theme will be
the basic interaction
with a Google Form,
container-bound scripts,
container extension,
Gmail's API,
Spreadsheet's
and Document's.
And this time,
we're going to use
container-bound scripts,
which is a concept
we already know,
but it's worth remembering
that they're those
only accessible
from Google Spreadsheet
and Google Document,
not from our Drive unit.
So we get further knowledge,
we'll integrate another service,
this time, Gmail,
which will clearly allow us
to send e-mails
with some data.
We intend to capture
some information
through the form.
We'll get a name,
an e-mail address
and a type of document.
Once the information
is in our spreadsheet,
the script will create a file
of the type indicated
and we'll send an e-mail
to those who registered,
including and attachment.
LET'S GET TO WORK
Let's enter Drive.
Let's select
"create a document,"
in this case, a Form.
With it we will pose
a couple of questions,
an open question
and a multiple choice question.
We then select
the template we will use:
"gas form."
Always using "gas."
We click on "OK"
and we now have our form.
Now we need to add
the questions.
The first, what do we want?
The name
of the persons
that will register.
So we will ask them to write it.
"Write your name."
What type of question is this?
It's a text question.
And let's make it
mandatory, required.
Let's continue...
We scroll down...
Done. So now we will add
another element.
The next piece of information
we want is an e-mail,
so we ask them to write
their e-mail address.
Write it.
"Write your e-mail."
What type of question is this?
It's also a text question,
but we will apply
a validation to it.
We're going to verify
that what's written there
has the right format
for an e-mail address.
We scroll down again,
we're losing it there...
And this one we will set it...
as a required field...
And...
Let's see...
let's check, yes, it's "Text,"
that's what we want.
Right choice...
Text is also what's going to be
inserted there,
and the e-mail validation,
that's what we want.
That's also mandatory,
it's a required field.
Did you notice it shows
that classic red asterisk?
There it is.
The next one
won't be a text question,
but a multiple choice one,
because we want the user
to be able to choose
one of two,
so we will ask him to select
the type of file to create,
the type of document, which is
the first option,
a Drive Document.
So option 1: Document.
Option 2: a Spreadsheet.
We're going to be working
with those two.
Spreadsheet.
We got it.
We got all the options.
This is mandatory too.
Now let's save it.
Done.
Now our form is complete.
Now let's select a destination
for the information.
As we can see,
it gives us a spreadsheet
by predetermination,
we just need to change
its name:
"spreadsheet gas form."
Then we confirm it.
And now we have associated
this spreadsheet
to the responses to our form.
Now let's see our form live,
as we would see it
in the Web.
There it is, we can see
the template we had set.
Let's register.
I write my name, Antonio,
and my e-mail address:
cuauhtli17@...
we wait for the "@"...
"@," there you go, gmail.com.
And we select one. Which one?
One of two: Document.
That way we've completed
the information requested,
now let's save it and submit it.
"Submit."
This way we'd have
one registration, but...
let's make one more
to see the other option
of the spreadsheet.
The same, "To–o",
we don't have a "–" key,
so we leave it as "Tono"...
the e-mail address is the same,
and now we select "Spreadsheet."
We submit it...
There's the spreadsheet
that we selected
to store the information
sent by the users
through the form.
It's loading...
It's called
"spreadsheet gas form,"
and there we have the 2
registrations we just inserted.
We put 3 questions,
therefor we have 3 columns,
their 3 correspondent columns
with their responses,
apart from a first column
which has the timestamp
for the information.
Now let's build our script.
You know: Tools > Script Editor.
It means we'll build
a container-bound script...
and another script, you know,
the welcome screen,
a blank project,
we want it all empty,
we will build it from scratch.
Now let's name our script,
in this case: "gas04,"
and we're going to start
writing our function.
We will reference
our spreadsheet.
"var sheet"...
We'll reference the sheet,
so...
we use the SpreadsheetApp class
and we get the one active
in the context
in which
we're calling our script.
Now let's create
another variable called Òrows."
In this one we will associate
the data that we have
in our form,
the registrations we have,
so we bring
all that data range we have.
So we're going to iterate
that data arrangement.
In order to do it correctly,
we're going to create
an auxiliary variable.
Because, if you noticed,
we had an extra registration,
which was the tops,
but we're not doing
anything with the tops,
so we will use "numRows"
as an auxiliary.
So...
now we can get the values.
So we declare our variable,
and on "rows" we get
this bidimensional arrangement
with all the data.
We already know we have
to use the method "getValues."
"getValues."
We hit "autocomplete"
to avoid mistakes...
a semicolon...
We finish our sentence.
We already have the data,
now what comes next
is starting to operate
on that arrangement
to be able to easily extract it
and start building what we want.
We're going to do it
inside a "for."
We'll use "for" as an auxiliary.
We assemble it...
semicolon...
and...
we'll start iterating.
We will use a variable "i"
that will start from position 1.
Then, "i" always has to be
less-than
the number of rows, the variable
we declared above,
and so, you know,
so it goes on,
we add an increment.
"i++."
There it is, our "i++."
So we start extracting
the data we have
in each one of those rows.
We have a mail,
so let's extract it now.
From where?
From "values".
And we put its
corresponding index.
Which is? Index 2,
because it's the third column.
And, remember, since it's
a bidimensional array,
we have to put
the reference too,
so now we get the name.
"name = values,"
so it gets it
from position "i".
And now
its corresponding column,
which is column 2.
It has another index, 1.
We'll get the type
of document
the user was requesting,
which is the file,
we iterate on "values..."
the index,
which we already have,
and now an auxiliary variable.
We will use it later on.
We will name it "file."
There. Now we have the data.
We have to validate it
so we know what to do.
If they want Document
or a Spreadsheet.
Let's put an "if,"
a classic "if else" structure.
"if file"
equals the chain "Document"
Docu...
Document.
So when that condition happens,
when it is true,
we're going
to create a document.
So we put our variable:
"doc = DocumentApp..."
We use this class,
"Document..."
"DocumentApp." There you go.
What do we want?
To create something,
so we use a "create" method
and we'll give it
the name of that document.
Remember,
it's a text chain, so:
"Document -04..."
and we will concatenate
the name of the user
that requests the file.
So we concatenate it
and now let's put
some content into it.
How? As we did it
in the previous lessons,
with the object.
We get its body,
and then we use the method
"appendParagraph,"
which will allow us
to add the content.
The content will be
a text chain,
so we pass it to it...
And we're going to write:
"Congratulations, you're now
using Google Apps Script."
We now have our text
in our document.
Now, let's use
the variable "file"
as an auxiliary,
and we take the reference.
Now we use the class
"DriveApp"
and we will bring
that...
that file through its ID.
So we use "doc.getID,"
and now we have a reference
to that document.
We will use it later on.
And what happened
when it wasn't Document?
It was the other case,
the Spreadsheet case.
There were 2 options only,
there's nothing left to validate
and we will submit that one.
And with "else"
we cover both cases,
so we're going to create
a Spreadsheet.
When there's not a document,
we need to create a Spreadsheet.
"SpreadsheetApp"
and let's use
the method "create..."
which also receives
a text chain,
in this case, the text will be
the name of this spreadsheet.
We write it...
"GAS 04..."
and we will also concatenate
the name to customize it,
the name of the person
who requested
this type of file.
We concatenate with "+,"
name...
We finish, ";" and the next one,
which is "var sheet."
We'll reference that 1st sheet
that our spreadsheet has.
So "get.Sheets,"
remember, it's an array
of all the sheets it has.
We just want the first one,
so we reference
the first element.
Once we have the sheet,
we will determine
the location for the value.
That we will do
by means of a range,
and we want it
in the first cell.
So it's: "1, 1."
Row 1, column 1.
And now we can add
"setValue..."
and once again it will be a text
to cheer you guys up:
"Congratulations,
you're now using GAS."
Google Apps Script.
"You're using GAS."
And, once again,
we use the variable "file"
to reference it from DriveApp,
"file = DriveApp,"
and we'll bring that reference
through the ID
of the spreadsheet we created.
So through ID:
"sps" and we ask it
to bring its ID.
"get...
ID."
We got it.
Then we save it...
";", we finish our sentence.
Now, what we want to do
is send that information
by e-mail.
So now he have
to use "GmailApp"
which has a method called
"send mail."
"Send mail" has two variants:
the simple one, and the one
that supports options.
We will use the second one,
because we want to include
an attachment.
If you see it,
it's pretty easy to use.
It needs a recipient, which one?
The e-mail of the person
that registered.
Then, we add a subject.
There we will write
a generic subject.
Let's write it. We're not
going to customize it this time.
"GAS-L4"
and a message body.
This body is limited to 20 Kb,
we can't fit a bigger one there.
Anyway, it's a small text.
We'll customize it
by putting a general salutation,
but what's going to change
is the name
of each user that has
filled out the form.
Now...
What are we missing?
We have the body message,
let's add our attachment.
It's worth mentioning
that the options are written
by using the JavaScript
Object Notation
so we'll do it that way.
The property we will use
is "attachment"
and then we will put its value.
What would that be?
A file. Which one?
The one we created
some lines above.
Now we save it.
Now we have the main part
of our functionality,
but we also wanted to build
a container-type script,
container extension...
so we can add a menu.
Let's insert another function,
the one we already know:
"function onOpen,"
and what we're going
to implement in that
is a menu from which,
every time you enter the sheet,
you can send the mails,
by choosing a menu option,
by clicking on a button.
Class SpreadsheetApp,
to reference
that sheet that's active,
"getActiveSpreadsheet",
and let's build the menu.
This is an arrangement
in which you include the text,
that will be the name
of the submenu,
and the function with which
it will be mapped.
Send e-mail...
That's how it will appear
on the screen once you see it.
That's what
the submenu will read.
And what function
is it mapped to?
To the one we just created
or implemented minutes ago:
"myFunction."
Now everything's set.
What's left?
Add it to the spreadsheet,
in this case,
to the first sheet.
Let's put it outside
because we're leaving it
in the same body
as "myFunction"
and that has to be separate.
We paste it...
And now we got it right,
otherwise, it wouldn't
recognize it as an adequate...
function...
to our purposes.
So, now we can do it,
we will put the menu
on the sheet
and... there it is.
Come on...
And we will name this menu...
Let's go to "Sender script"
and there we have
a "send e-mail" option.
Let's select it
and our script starts to run.
It lets us know it's done.
So, right now,
we can go to our e-mail inbox
and verify that the mails
are really there.
So let's go to Gmail.
There they are, both mails,
because I entered
my e-mail address twice.
We open one of them...
and there is our mail.
We can see there is
an attachment included
and the customized salutation
we'd added:
"Hello, user" and that's it.
Let's go back, there's the data.
Go to Tools,
Script Editor, y let's verify
that this information
we saw in the e-mail
is the same as that we wrote
in the script, in the body.
There it is.
The customized salutation:
"Thank you for registering."
And we go back to Drive
to verify
that the documents
we'd requested really exist.
There they are, a document
and a spreadsheet.
So we open the document...
and there's the body:
"Congratulations, you're now
using Google Apps Script."
And so we've finished
our exercise.
With this example
we've given you,
we can confirm Google Apps
Script versatility,
because we could integrate
several services
that Google Apps
are composed of.
Besides, we could discover
the possibilities
these services' APIs offer.
LET'S DO AN EXERCISE
In order to reinforce
today's lesson,
I invite you to develop
the following exercise:
Imagine that,
in your e-mail inbox,
you have the messages
from a contact form
and that they need
and automated response.
So, build a script
that takes the first 7 messages,
and for all those
that are unread,
give the following response:
"Thank you for contacting us.
We're working on your request
and we will give you a response
as soon as possible."
We also have to highlight
these e-mails
and associated to a user tag.
RECAPITULATION
In this lesson we worked
with the basic interaction
of a Google Form.
We also used
container-bound scripts,
container extension scripts,
and the APIs of Gmail,
Spreadsheet and Document.
That will be all for now.
See you next time.
Keep on programming.